hey everyone my name is Jake and I'm
with Joey and we're back with more far
cry 5 arcade Maps we've got a pretty
good selection I feel like they're
starting to get really good now yeah so
if you know is actually the the star
rating on all of them they're actually
like getting up to four and five stars
as more people are playing them and
appreciating them I guess yeah and so I
picked out three do you picked out one
we're gonna start with a soap garage
which you found yeah and it's sitting at
four stars a little bit more than four
stars that's over four author is a dog
gun twenty-one okay so we got assault
this was just a baseball bat spike that
and then in filtration uh I think what
they pull through yeah I'd go an
infiltration ooh were you driving that
car that just crashed probably Joey Joey
Joey so there's not a whole lot to it
like in terms of you know theming or
anything there's no like weird catch or
weird like gimmick that love other maps
do but this one's like well constructed
a ladder right there yeah that's cool
top so like a lot of times that's all it
takes like just with what you have and
the time you have just sorry I changed
those buttons no just got ours because
you knew Oh what's this that's an RPG
you got a silencer are you just gonna
blast some notes are from my RPG well
you should take out the and let's say we
want to get everyone if you can take out
the alarm oh okay or you can kill him
with a silenced weapon I think you have
one of those right
you shouldn't point blank with that
sniper is this is a silenced yeah a
silenced yeah so there's a little gas
station right here got some trail some
trailers over there a shooting range
flight training and tour there's a
helicopter to wonder if I can take that
Oh someone someone spotted bodies that's
okay one alarm oh there's another alarm
you got to be careful Oh
oh I can't believe I miss oh my god you
choked in you got him
I got swings so can I do the
reinforcements now you just you just
gotta fight fire with fire right oh yeah
got him to left piece of cake
I saw his I saw his sight somewhere oh
all right one left
just get it let's get a close-up RPG
shot and hope I don't blast myself in
the back closed but pretty close there
is see going he's running towards you oh
here we go perfect
alright shovel soles I assume this has
something to do with either shovel
knight or Dark Souls one of the Dark
Souls okay there's one by John John
three five six this one I think is
really cool obviously a lot of people
have played this and it's been around
for a while but we haven't covered it
and I figured it's a good one to do
because it's it's really well made
really cool alright so what are we gonna
be we gonna be a cleric a night so I got
Victor Horta prize shovel and a knife
we got a Molotov mmm I'm gonna go with
the name my namesake the shovel okay
nice nice little atmosphere here I
forgot which Dark Souls this is based
off of it looks like I want to say it's
two or three I think I don't remember
but it's pretty dang cool he has a
really really good environment yeah
though the lighting and the fog ear they
somehow managed to make it look Dark
Souls II to like with like the dead
trees and the statues and stuff like
that
where's my shovel oh yeah you got it you
got to stick with the shovel oh no
where'd the other one go
she threw something oh nice
all right but what's dark souls without
applause oh and of course they throw the
hardest enemy at you he doesn't seem to
be uh
bothered by my no my attacks he's thrown
a lot of bats at him too maybe he's just
know they always lure you into that
false sense of security in any one hit
but she totally wasn't it was me at the
end yeah but he get to hit Kay oh yeah
he's slowing down
oh yeah there we go
yes congratulations you defeated the
boss but now you got to get to the end
there we go there we go we escaped what
do you think I thought it's pretty cool
yeah it's neat what you can do with it
alright so this one is APA hard parkour
challenge it is by APA I can't read that
from here but anyway it is an obstacle
course which I think it's cool is
someone who's been messing around with
farcry map better a lot it's something I
always enjoyed but I think this is way
more interesting than your typical
obstacle course hmm and you'll probably
know why very quickly
yeah remind you of anything resident of
portal oh yeah starting this little oh
wait what you know here of course so the
catch is instead of using portals and
stuff you have to do an obstacle course
Oh Oh Jim
maybe this one is nope oh nice
there we go the the next couple of a
bunch easier whoo there you go something
happened here
I need to lower yourself yeah there you
go
swing builder quick just be aware of my
surroundings you'll get it
oh that was cheap that was unfair sweet
there you go
and there you go and will he make it he
made it but he's not done yet okay nice
thank you as you can see it's kind of
like deteriorating
I never tried that Oh cuz it's locked
here I see oh is that me
sure like on the other side of them okay
wow that was a nice jump I was amazed
you made that six okay this is this is
where I got o overcorrected okay I
accept a feat I think you're good oh boy
but now can you jump back up on there
and just like but don't don't mantle I
know I think ya like that
okay oh man I don't know oh wait Oh
further is that a jump you you make I
think really so this last one comes to
us by a viewer actually uh Devin
Almighty created this and he said we
should check it out he actually created
two one was like a mini version of Far
Cry five like there were three different
areas and you start in the center but I
picked this one because it's a little
bit quicker and I like the like the mood
at set normal badass ninja or poor I
think I picked ninja goggle with badass
all right got a flamethrower so one
thing I will say wow you've started
quite the fire one thing I will say
though is that there are two little
towns so after there's no one left here
gonna have to get in the car okay
because I spent a while trying to find
out where the rest of the people were
and if you just get in the car and fall
out the road you find
what
I used my flamethrower like twice in
that area but fire Joey you should have
built it with wood see this place made
of brick it's not gonna burn yeah most
maps that we've seen we've either like
just they just jump you or they just put
you straight into a town where you like
assault or they have you drive to a
place where I haven't seen many that
like have you start in one place and end
in another yeah I I think it would be
cool if they were like little outposts
and stuff maybe like maybe one outpost
along the way yeah it's your progress I
think that could be interesting but here
we are throwing beer cans out the window
this is also I think one of the few
instances where I wish there were more
enemies like I didn't really get to
explore this area they all just kind of
started shooting at me and I killed them
and finished it yeah because this this
area is actually a lot bigger than the
first yeah oh hi there
yeah so there you go that was a good one
actually yeah like I I agree with what
you said about the the second area yeah
I'm having a little bit more just bad
guys there but overall yeah like having
to go between places okay so those are
the maps we picked out this week however
should we do a couple roulette
you know let's do a couple okay four
stars to start off here that's probably
good Rambo well I mean obviously we're
gonna have to be Rambo I think that's a
team okay all right
oh wait whoops thing as a friendly
alright where it's just look out you
know
see I'm Rambo I work I work alone
oh wow what's the line in that get it
it's as easy as breathing nice all right
it's one way to get down this hill
alright I'll continue I'm just gonna go
on foot assume it's down here somewhere
right
it's a big one to one I'm not sure how
that kill to him would not me where are
the other ones
get up yeah I think so
I see you oh oh well that went not as
plan but much better than I expected
alright next up we got a dark and stormy
night this is a today actually alright
55 people played it we're uh
one of the first testers here let's go
stealth oh my is really dark in the room
that we're anymore yeah and the room
that we're in is so much clearer you
know I'm gonna turn off the lights I
might be able to see better okay a
little bit it's not love not a lot of
help but those little flashes of
lightning every so often no I get it you
want to follow those lights see ya yeah
it's like Alan Wake let's head back down
oh oh you can do a chain take down yeah
about that okay
nine left
oh no okay I'm okay
no health or no uh bandages pick up his
rocket though there you go this is what
I need all right okay I got four rocket
she's got enough one for each of you and
then one for myself okay one of them's
up here pretty sure yeah you're right
somewhere I have no idea where you at I
don't see them on the you I get on that
turret truck to start firing and see if
that gets his attention
aha
no no no keep oh there you go you peed
on your anything now I see him sweet all
right uh that one was a little too dark
I think I think that's it for this week
thank you guys for tuning in once again
and like I said before if you have any
recommendations feel free to send them
our way on Twitter just be weary that
it's really tough for us to demo
multiplayer maps so try to keep it to
solo and co-op and hopefully we'll see
you guys again next week
yeah